>> This is one face of Russia's
hybrid war to destabilize
Ukraine's tiny neighbor,
Moldova.
An organized pro-Russian
protest.
Whipped up by apparent pro
Russian political provoke
utters, claiming intimidation,
calling for the overthrow of
Moldova's prime minister.
It's just one element in a
sinister, secret Russian
intelligence document obtained
by CNN.
Systematically laying out ways
to bring down the nation's
western-leaning leaders.
In addition to organize
protests, options include
utilizing the orthodox church,
threatening to cut off energy
supplies.
It's ten your strategy, titled
strategic objectives of the
Russian Federation, and into
the republic of Moldova,
appears to have been written
two years ago by Russia's kgb
replacement, the fsb.
The --
creation of stable pro Russian
groups of influence and the
formation of negative attitudes
towards nato.
Moldova officials, increasingly
seeing its volatile effects.
>> It's black propaganda,
actually, is getting too many
people in the form of
manipulation that the western
and European integration path
will not only leave the country
to war.
>> Russia's aggression appears
triggered by Moldova's shift to
the west.
Reaction to Russia's war in
Ukraine.
>> The Kremlin spokesman denies
the fsb plan exists, dismisses
it as a fake.
But only last year, Russian
military officials were
boasting battlefield games in
southern Ukraine, would soon
link Russia with Russian troops,
and the pro-Russian breakaway
transnistria region of Moldova.
>> It didn't happen but a few
days later, tensions spiked,
has two radio towers in the
separatist region were blown
up.
No details emerged, but the fsb
plan raises troubling questions
about the possibility of a
false flag operation.
And Russian missiles en route
to --
in Ukraine routinely fly close
to or even inside Moldova.
Last month, triggering a
shutdown of Moldovan airspace.
Also looked less accidental,
more intentional.
In light of the report.
>> [Interpreter]
We permanently as for the
unconditional evacuation of the
reasons for since, which are
illegally stationed in
Moldova's territory, including
the evacuation of the
ammunition depot in Kozma.
[End of translation]
>> Western allies are
increasingly showing
solidarity.
The uk's foreign secretary, the
latest high-profile visitor,
offering no weapons, but a
strong support.
>> One of the best ways that we
can help physically protect
Moldova from harm is to ensure
the Ukrainians are able to
defend themselves against
Russian attacks.
>> As long as Russia remains on